l'ho fatto ora ti leggo approfitta però
così non potrei di scappare
[Musica]
sì
quella che stasera
[Musica]
ice cream e laggiù vista ben tornati
sani terzo il nuovo episodio trova gli
ingredienti time questa volta dovrò
trovare gli ingredienti slime nascosti
da rod ice cream se questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace ci sarà un
nuovo video con ice cream come sempre
dovrò trovare tutti gli ingredienti e
fare lo slime per vincere la challenge
se vengo preso a questa volta solo una
volta avrò perso la salle anche perché
sapete che se ice cream ti prende ti
congela etica dentro una gabbia quindi
non potrò più fare lo slam sicuramente
dentro la gabbia che pronti
mettetevi comodi prenditi pop corn e
iniziamo la nostra ricerca stanno
uscendo dal campo lo vedrete
novelli che mi aspetta vaime ritrovai a
prenderlo maledizione con patch a cercar
di ladins istanze lì che mi aspetta che
fa mirino
ok si sta allontanando avviciniamoci
piano piano
[Musica]
questo è rientrato dentro
sono sicura che gli ingredienti sono
dentro il suo camioncino dei gelati
purtroppo
marino non vedere se c'è qualcosa
squadrito si sta vicino non so come ma
sono riuscita a recuperare la ciotola
era dentro al suo camioncino dei gelati
proprio all'entrata ancora lì forse
quando mi vede
ok
sta andando via
dobbiamo anche controllare ogni minimo a
nicolò perché gli ingredienti potrebbero
essere ovunque tipo potrebbero essere
così come può essere a fianco a me ma
devo dire che questa challenge sta
andando su per bene per ora anche se il
nemico questa volta è molto cattivo è
molto più difficile sconfiggerlo non mi
sembra che ci sia nessuno
non sento niente però devo dire che
questi gelati sembrano super buoni
guardate ne vorrei davvero uno adesso
chissà se roth mangia davvero i gelati o
trasforma solo le persone in gelati lui
è cattivo perché trasforma le persone in
gelati quindi vuol dire che tutti questi
girati in realtà prima erano delle
persone andando la voglio più mangiare
come si apre è molto grande e qua sento
dei rumori amore che si stia avvicinando
forse con questa mappa riuscirò a
trovare gli ingredienti
forse devo controllarla bene
a mio avviso per fortuna devo sbrigarmi
devo cercare apriamo tutti i cassetti
no niente c'è qualcosa per le padelle
per cucinare i gelati soluzione per le
sorti della forza e sulla porta no come
si chiude sta provando ad aprire la
porta devo tenerla chiusa è molto più
forte di me non pensa di riuscire a
tenere la porta chiesa a lungo tutto
fermo 16 tra doveri che faccio
quando qua dietro
com'era giorno siete
non mi ha visto sta tornando indietro
ok ha chiuso la porta per fortuna mi
sono nascosta
dobbiamo scappare a meno che non mi
nascondo qua sopra in questo sorta di
lettino ripostiglio aspettiamo quindi
carbonato io ho trovato due cose qua
dentro
approfittiamo per fatto che sappiamo non
riesco ad aprirla sono chiusa a chiave
non so se abbia visto per fortuna è
molto lento non riesci a prendermi bene
posso anche passeggiare tanto e super
lento c'è qualcosa di strano perché è
rimasto immobile pepe non c'è tempo
adesso per capire che cosa sta tramando
abbiamo il bicarbonato la ciotola la
spatola è la soluzione per letti quindi
sapete cosa vuol dire che manca solo una
cosa fondamentale la colla ave ragazzi
siamo tornati fuori
ho come l'impressione che la colla sia
dentro al camioncino dei gelati di rod
se fosse qua fuori sarebbe troppo facile
quindi purtroppo dovremo risalire però
non vedo rotta quindi sicuramente là
dentro
se non equa in giro che cammina sarà là
dentro la quindi siamo molto attenti e
là dentro che fa e l'immobile questa che
è la corda possa fare questa corda come
potrei usarla
mi è venuta un'idea ma tiriamo rotte in
una trappola e li chiamo ei signor
gelataio o un gelato buonissimo per te o
no aspetta non ho pensato bene questa
cosa
come faccio a legarle una volta che si
avvicina e aspetta devo andare a premere
questa sera le tendenze l'acqua si
aspetti un momento qui fermo vado a
prenderla mia vista
signor gelataio ice cream e ho quindi
gelato e proprio qua vicino questo
albero guarda e qua dentro
e proprio cosa guarda caso cofattore ti
leggo a questo basterà così non potrai
più scappare
svegliamoci prima che riesca a liberarsi
non ci riesco a credere che esistano
riuscita anche se berlino era un po in
mezzo alle scatole però alla fine ci
sono riuscita
o no guardate si è già legato
[Musica]
jack
no
proviamo ad aprire qua forse la scuola è
qua si vuole una chiave valentia si
vuole la chiave la libera un posto si
torna la chiave anche qua visto aperto
basta iniziati benzina forse qua dentro
forse la con acqua stanza di benzina
vuota
pensavo di aver trovato la colla ma in
non per forza risalire la ottobre
chiuderà la porta in questo mini durerà
a lungo su come si chiedeva in chiave
controllato lato più trovata ho trovato
la colla ragazzi ora devo solo scappare
e andare a farlo slime lo trovassi re
accoglierli
lei è andato via giudicarmi devo cercare
qualcosa per difendermi che cosa c'è un
estintore potrebbe funzionare
non lo so speso un sacco
non so se può funzionare per difendermi
testa tantissimo di riuscire a
difendermi con questa
peccati questo e fifa
scappiamo rimasto paralizzato
scappiamo prima che svanisca l'affetto
la colla dove lo ammetto però che
l'effetto dell'estintore duri molto
essere qualcosa che c'era nel camper e
la colla che si illumina al buio ed è
verde gialla
il carbonato becchiamoci
non mi sembra di sentire niente
e ancora paralizzato dall'istinto e
mescoliamo tutto guardate che bello
nuovo play non è ancora pronto ma si sta
avvicinando
eccolo qua e che per prime
ce l'abbiamo un po questa volta come uno
slam che si illumina al buio è stato
difficile con road ma alla fine ce
l'abbiamo fatta praticamente questo
slime la crema del gelato mi raccomando
e lasciate un mi piace se volete un
altro episodio con ice cream
se volete un altro trolley ingredienti
slime a 30 mila mi piace ci sarà un
altro episodio e ora vi lasciamo a 4
caselline squeaky cario per vedere i
miei altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao